les premières images du télescope james
webb inspire beaucoup d'internautes des
galaxies lointaines où certains voient
briller la pochette du prochain album de
beyoncé ou une des montres molles de
salvador dali d'autres s'amusent à
comparer l'incomparable la netteté de
l'univers il ya plus de quatre milliards
et demi d'années lumière et celle de
leurs caméras de surveillance
[Musique]
aya notre beauté russe qui a l'air
d'avoir le souffle coupé c'est marion
qui vous fait cet effet là très joliment
en plus c'est vous avez remarqué quand
elle bouge c'est non mais quelle
féminité fait comme ça au j'adore cette
fille et qui nous donne
[Musique]
un milliard
c'est un mélange est explosif ça
maintenant mais depuis trois jours vous
êtes d'une naïveté mais incroyable dire
votre l'histoire de me2 de macron et de
hubert ah bon il ya des labit a qui font
des amendements à l'assemblée nationale
avait et puis et puis sachant que les
plus gros qui les plus gros lobby
salades
des mauvaises causes et ça ça me gêne
aussi
c'est le symbole d'une majorité qui
risquent de souffrir pendant cinq ans
cette nuit l'assemblée nationale a
adopté le nouveau projet de loi
sanitaire mais en l'amputant d'un
article clé la nuque baisse le
rassemblement national et les
républicains se sont coordonnés pour
rejeter l'article 2 qui prévoyait un
possible retour du patient ni terre aux
frontières lors des voyages depuis ou
vers l'étranger est ce que vous savez
d'où vient l'expression faire une
vacherie à quelqu'un eh bien ça a un
rapport direct avec nos vaches sous
leurs airs paisibles elle déteste être
dérangé et l on voit facilement un coup
de sabot bien placés pour le faire
savoir et bien c'est à cause de ces
attaques sournoises qu'on parle de faire
une vacherie ou constate quelqu'un de
peau de vache
l'heure est grave en s'alliant pour
voter contre les mesures de protection
des français face au co vide elle est
fille l'ailer et le r n empêche tout
contrôle aux frontières face au virus
ville sur tuiles des voir déboires ces
biens
jusqu'à 18 millions d'euros de faux test
pour un seul pharmaciens des chiffres
vertigineux qui ont alerté
l'administration
une enquête a permis de révéler que
pendant la crise du coc vite des
pharmaciens en ont profité pour
s'enrichir au total 34 pharmacies sont
accusés de fraude auprès de l'assurance
maladie montant du préjudice plus de 53
millions d'euros ils ont tous une
bouteille de l'huile de bas 2-2 copeaux
de coco et puis moi après je vous remets
sur la tête
avec sa
[Musique]
valise
[Rires]
très bon sens des tranquillement
[Musique]
nico j'ai envie de le jeter dans la
piscine c'est un crado ils me dégoûtent
ont causé le pire m tu bois d'oeuvre h
et je me rase a déjà est la première
édition make me lâche ok